here with more texas senator ted cruz
senator let's start with uh merrick
garland and really or terry mcauliffe's
comments parents have no right to say
what uh have a say about their
children's education why don't we just
hand the kids over to the government let
them raise them because apparently
that's what they want
well you know in any crisis someone's
character is revealed and covid really
has shown the character of the democrats
they are authoritarians they are
jack-booted thugs there is no decision
about your life that they will not try
to control whether that is a vaccine
mandate regardless of your choices gavin
newsom trying to order every school kid
in california to get a vaccine
regardless of their parents wishes or
or whether it comes to silencing free
speech you know at the attorney
general's memorandum this week he
directed the fbi and the department of
justice to go after parents who are
going to school boards who are
expressing dismay that critical race
theory the toxic stew of lies that
divides us based on race that teaches
kids that america is inherently racist
that all white people are racist that
seeks to turn us
into hating each other on racial lines
parents are understandably upset about
that
and the attorney general told the
department of justice that those parents
at school boards should be treated as
threats and as domestic terrorists and
directed the fbi to use all the forces
of the federal government against them
today and you put up just a minute ago
the hearing with the head of the civil
rights
division of the department of justice i
asked her i said do you really think
parents at school boards are domestic
terrorists she refused to answer the
question i said well well do they have
any civil rights to express their dismay
to their elected officials the head of
the civil rights division refused to
answer it then i asked sean i said well
what about antifa what about antifa
terrorists that are rioting across the
country are they domestic terrorists
she refused to answer that i said how
about black lives matter terrorists that
are looting stores and firebombing
police cars and murdering police
officers can we agree that if you murder
police officers you're a domestic
terrorist
she said well
everybody is allowed to have a point of
view so the biden justice department
looks at
terrorists who are murdering police
officers and firebombing cities and says
we don't know if they're bad guys but
they look at moms at a pta meeting and
they say yup
that is the threat in life it's nuts
it's it's madness we're gonna have a lot
more the great one mark levine will
weigh in tonight senator i want to ask
you something here i have very strong
feelings uh you tell me correct me if
i'm wrong but i don't think any
republican was consulted in any way at
all
never mind any meaningful way on the 3.5
trillion dollars in new green deal
socialism now to pay for that
the democrats are trying to rely on
republicans to assist them in raising
the debt ceiling or else they won't have
the money to spend on their socialism
which will destroy this great country uh
and i don't want a single republican i'm
a conservative as you know i don't want
a single republican assisting them by
raising the debt ceiling and i heard
mitch mcconnell might be opening the
door to allow that to happen that's not
uh particularly pleasing to me and that
doesn't sound like a small government
conservatism to me
yeah look you're preaching to the choir
i think it is a big big mistake
as you'll remember sean the first book i
wrote was called a time for truth and
the opening chapter of a time for truth
the title of it was mendacity and it
described the senate republican lunch
where mitch mcconnell asked every
republican to unanimously consent to
lower the threshold for the democrats to
raise the debt ceiling from 60 votes to
50 votes and and i raised my hand i said
listen there is no universe in which i
can consent to that
it's dishonest to the men and women who
elected us there's nothing i've done in
nine years in the senate that is more
enraged leadership than that moment of
objecting and we're right back there
again again republicans are being asked
to consent to lower the threshold and
this is all because chuck schumer is
playing political games right now the
democrats have both houses of congress
in the white house they can raise the
debt ceiling but schumer doesn't want to
because if they raise it with just
democrat votes and they actually have to
be honest to the voters and say yes
we're adding trillions in debts to our
kids and grandkids
instead they want to play a game that
forces republicans to support their
massive debt and their reckless spending
schumer is the one who is threatening a
default of the debt biden is the one who
is threatening a default of the debt
that is reckless we should never ever
ever default on the debt and by the way
for years i've supported legislation
called the full faith and credit act
that would say under no circumstances
would the united states
ever default on its debt if a debt
ceiling isn't raised we will continue to
pay the interest on our debt and it will
be the big government left-wing spending
programs that are cut instead but the
democrats block it because they want to
threaten the default on the debt to push
through more spending programs
all right senator stand strong the
american people will stand behind you
every conservative will most republicans
mitch mcconnell
stand up as a conservative or let
someone else lead thank you i'm steve
ducey i'm brian killman and i'm ainsley
earhardt and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis